Oh who's this little thick nugget Oh God
right here man who's this little [ __ ]
thick tenderoni ha ha you don't think it
could be a filter is that he's using on
them yeah I know you think when I see
her brother yeah good call man
looks like an australian bean pies guts
got a debate club topic for you all
right
you gotta get up in the middle of night
go take a leak mmm on the light no are
you just going about sound mm-hmm me
personally I like ya meet you brother
know what job thing Gang Gang but I feel
like we go by sound brother probably the
same problem I have all you here's your
bread you're breathing I do the Ray
Charles I just feel things out here my
breathing and I don't try like because I
don't want to keep you up for a while
and then I take that hard
super soaker for you oh I pee so hard in
the night cuz I drink so many fluids oh
I'm never not if you notice any show I
do even at home I'm never not drinking
something you're always having fluids
always have something my mouth ooh like
I've never run Stuart have you seen that
movie yes good movie I say I think it's
fun to go no light until you start to
get a little older and then it gets real
risky going no light yeah that's the
part I find one stray shoe I'm lazy you
know I'll put the take the shoes off and
get right into bed there's no not a lot
of middle ground you know in between you
know I'll take the shoes off I'll have
one of those
peppermint York patty one of these
you're like I'm gonna brush my teeth in
the morning I'm gonna have this tonight
yeah and I'll get straight into bed so
then I get up in them on the night I got
to do urine and I don't it's really it's
a minefield cuz those shoes are out
there the pants you know you you you
want to take the road a little you know
you want make things difficult for you
yeah it's I don't do a ninja warrior
yeah you're getting a little more ninja
warrior and it's risky and sometimes
I'll I'll toe I'll just hold the line
bro you know I'm saying I'll just batten
down the hatch squeeze my wiener and go
back to sleep you never
I peed hard really it's done it's it's a
nice feeling you little [ __ ] dogs dummy
that bladder bro I dumped that bladder
and it's loud I'm rod that thing and
just have a stressful [ __ ] two more
hours of sleep no painful [ __ ] hours
I like that full feeling in my body
that's not gay bro I guess a water
mother I'd ride rain that thing you do
do I empty at all you sit down to pee at
night or Santa I stand up and I always
put my head in the wall see a print on
the wall what are you even see a print
because I died like this I'm like
leaning like this I'm on my
tighty-whities
what and I'm breathing hard oh that's
that German style that's like a black
man at church I told you I Ray Charles
if I can hear it splatting on the kind
of the top of the lid so I gotta pull it
back oh yeah yeah dad now once I get
into the bathroom then I use sound and
no one on P and if that's what he's
talking about don't know if he's talking
about getting to the toilet once I get
there though if I do have the lights off
I will pee for sound oh I don't I don't
shoot the straight stream right off the
bat I'd do a little few drips and hit
listen for the sound Oh real like oh we
good we clear the land and then I
[ __ ] dump it you guys do I pee so
much judging so many fluids dude it
makes me uncomfortable to pee directly
in the water I like to pee on the side
of the toilet like you interior talk
about the silencer test yes silencer
yeah I always use that it could be
Australian so Wow I'll wake up the whole
house it's so loud oh you'll wake up
Whitney's horses dude she's about seven
of them he's got endangered species in
her bed but yeah man I did so yeah I go
in there I'll go lightless but if I do I
still even in the dark we'll try to aim
for this space me too between the top of
the toilet and the top of the water you
don't hit a bull's-eye yeah mmm it's
disgusting you know that pees directly
under the water is going to hell agree
oh okay yeah so I guess I should change
I'm trying to wear a nice shirt today
would you no problem no you look nice
you look nice too oh they change
look man I'll take a light beer all
right light beer I was just gonna pop
off over some bottle surface I'm here
for jazz night all right I got the evite
I'm in I want that van drove dude
[Music]